Josh good morning how are you guys
we're doing okay we just got word that
looks like lay beyond bail might be
suspended the first four games of the
season you guys open up with Pittsburgh
did you hear about that yeah all in the
whole circle on the gambit of this
morning
okay you you want to face it do you want
to face a team when they're they got all
their stars there or are you kind of
saying hey I'm fine if labeling bills
not there on the field that they see you
they're awesome
he's not there awesome I mean that's
what it is for me young with the pennant
I love to see past do that playing gets
ugly the same time someone else won't
take its place
I probably have just as much to see this
and as D'Angelo I mean I put it when you
look at so I know what I'm juicy brings
until on how often do you guys drug
tested in the offseason no matter where
you at homicide Bri that and they'll get
their testing you should miss a field
test field test before game and I mean
it's know things I wish they'd put into
the system to learn um they can test
randomly if they feel this need to baby
where's the most random place you've
been asked to give a urine sample
Wow a picnic no privacy vivacious go
ahead no do you do Wow Wow who I mean
I'm finally giving them cell phone care
oh yeah
I know that you were with with the
Panthers obviously you saw where the
all-star games being pulled out of
Charlotte did you get that saw that news
I thought I saw that man I saw that but
you know I took it as well well done you
sticking to your guns don't want to move
you out of what you think is right if
you feel that's where you want to go
with it and so be it shoot if that's
your you know your beliefs and what you
believe in and that's that's your bad
but they don't nobody you know come and
move him from what they thought it you
know that's commendable
he's Josh Norman the Redskins defensive
back joining us on behalf of discover
boating dot-com how'd you get involved
in this well I know that one day Ron
about it ran two cool guys from there
they was just like well hey so it makes
sense for you know us to come on along
and they ended up meeting with a team
Archdemon we'll figure some stuff out in
a sense really did so was just you know
made this thing happen and now I'm we're
into this boating thing that's just
really about to do a big epidemic for us
well I'll see them be big into it so
it's got to be nice you can check it had
another one of the things I do you can
check out their boat selector tool which
can help you find the right boat for the
type of budget activities as well at
discover boating calm I saw Odell
Beckham jr. again coming up with convert
you're in conversation with Odell I
guess GQ he said he made you relevant
there that's pretty nice of him right
have you run into him off the field
well what happened late you're in New
York City what happens if you ran into
Odell Beckham how would it go I know man
I guess you guys
are you tired of the topic are you tired
of everybody I'm sure he hears about it
one way that way one way this way is
always something I mean you got here in
New York crazed fans they hear about it
really is non-stop epidemic that took
place is not like a giant best cancer a
shadow where we walk is that
conversation yeah it feels like dang man
I won't play ball yeah like she's on the
field outside of it something so much
bigger
well now you you faced him twice during
the regular season so that's why it's
ramped up even more I know is just
taking on a whole new face telling
nothing for me I know where I am
efficient bursting all-pro propolis
first out what's a soup bowl I have a
comment about Bill to say what I've done
I don't have to go back for what for
there's no need a contractor speaks for
itself
I'm on a fresh team that I'll try and
get to the Super Bowl that's our main
focus our goal but the more that's less
fall short of that come back next year
and try it again
I mean this is what we do oh look at you
know picking sides answer people what
not gonna make me any better
how long have you looked at the watch
the Super Bowl over yeah so I just know
it when I came out of it and try to be
better for my team now they experience
being there and know what it's like to
be on the other end
not you know when I try to whatever we
get back there do some positives dude
you know we shouldn't have any I think
that's they got to throw how excited are
you for that week 15 Monday night game
against your former team
oh man I'm excited for every every last
beat I get to play ball and she's a
question I can't but that we and in
general it's just gonna be Magda five
tops and for me I do because those guys
told me you know how we play I know how
they play they can read me Romilly
they're my back of my hand but I've been
in so long and playing those guys
instead of each fun because I mean I've
been all my life
now going through teams something fresh
so of course I'm a half fun with a fine
down the field boy it's time to go
change does Cam Newton have a tell you
know as a defensive back that you you
know what to look for
can't a man can't give away secrets
oh no but you got you could tell me that
there is a tell you don't have to tell
me what the tell is I'll see maybe it's
discovery can kill me I know I know I
know I know
it's discover boding calm he's Josh
Norman the Redskins quarterback hey
thanks for joining us and camps getting
ready to start good luck absolutely have
HP PR that's Norman the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you